what would happen after 14 days two
weeks
if you took a cold shower
every single day that's what we're going
to talk about we're going to do a deep
dive into this topic now you may have
heard of this guy called iceman he's
wrote a book he's done youtube videos he
developed the wim hof method using
things like ice baths cold showers to
improve your health i'm going to talk
about some of the benefits and the
research revolving around using
cryotherapy or
cold therapy now before you click off
and say there is no way in heck i am
going to ever take a cold shower
just hear me out because there are some
seriously positive
benefits from doing this and you can do
it very very gradually so it's not very
uncomfortable okay now i'm serious
all right now you would think that
going out in the cold when it's rainy
and it's cold you would you'd get sick
that's because your parents told you to
stay out of that rain it's cold out
there you're going to get a cold just
stay inside where it's nice and warm
well it just so happens that when you
expose your body to the cold i'm not
talking long term just a short term
your immune system becomes enhanced
you get more monocytes and lymphocytes
these are white blood cells that fight
off pathogens
you have a boost of t helper cells the t
helper cell is like the quarterback of
the entire immune system
okay you also get a spike of t
suppressor cells that help to calm down
an overactive immune system so they
prevent too much destruction of the
immune system so it's kind of a system
where your immune system is fighting
things off yet you have other factors
that are making sure there's not too
much collateral damage so your immune
system is enhanced when you expose it to
cold which is very very
counter-intuitive
number two you get a spike of
noradrenaline noradrenaline is similar
to adrenaline
and when they tested people that have
anxiety
attention deficit disorder
depression they usually have low
noradrenaline so by using this amazing
method of exposing yourself to cold you
can spike noradrenaline and improve your
overall mood so if you're depressed you
can pull yourself out of that lower
emotion if you have anxiety excessive
worry things like that you it can
elevate your emotion it can help your
cognitive function
your focus
your memory you can become more alert so
apparently our bodies have evolved over
eons to adapt to things like
cold
hunger starvation so our bodies through
this process have developed certain type
of adaptive survival mechanisms to
improve our health to survive better
when exposed to cold and hunger and
things like that
it's called the hormetic effect and a
hormetic effect is when you expose
someone to a stress
and then the body adapts and becomes
stronger like exercise would give you a
hormetic effect
fasting would give you a hormonal effect
taking a cold shower would definitely do
it all right the next thing is that
taking a cold shower is going to help
you lose weight how well
when you take a cold shower
you're going to trigger
brown fat another term for brown fat is
brown adipose
tissue
so the sensation of cold is the
main stimulus to stimulating brown fat
so the more cold the more brown fat that
you have now what's so significant about
this brown fat versus the white fat or
white adipose tissue
well brown fat increases heat
energy and metabolism your metabolism is
going to be raised when you have more
brown fat you're going to lose more
weight and brown fat will also trigger
more loss of white fat which is
the storage fat that you have in your
body okay so that's pretty cool in fact
100 grams of brown fat can burn
3 400 calories per day that's more
calories than you potentially could eat
in a given day so we want more brown fat
on our body another reason why it can
help you lose weight it can create an
increase in insulin sensitivity okay
if you've been watching my videos the
more you improve insulin sensitivity the
less insulin that's going to be produced
because it's going to work now and
there's going to be less resistance to
insulin and the more weight loss you're
going to have the better the blood
sugars you're going to have
so if you have diabetes your
pre-diabetes and you take a cold shower
you're going to notice that your blood
sugars actually come into check much
better and when that happens you're
going to lose weight number five
cold showers help with inflammation they
are anti-inflammatory
so if you have inflammation in your body
if you have some type of autoimmune
disease if you have
arthritis bursitis tendinitis taking a
cold shower would be a very therapeutic
thing number six
cold showers can increase your overall
antioxidant networks okay more
antioxidants the less dna damage the
less risk of getting cancer and other
diseases number seven neural protection
okay cold showers help your brain and so
apparently cold activates the regrowing
of neurons okay so that's pretty cool
and also as a side note when you're cold
you have a much better sleep now this is
within reason okay i'm talking about
freezing i'm just talking about having
the temperature a little bit cooler you
will sleep a little bit better so
another benefit i forgot to add on to
this is sleep all right number eight
longevity why because
cold showers stimulate autophagy just
like fasting stimulates autophagy
autophagy is a condition that your body
gets into where it's recycling old
damaged proteins okay
so if there's certain things that aren't
working in the body like their proteins
or enzymes or their mitochondria or
they're they're plaquing in the brain as
in amyloid plaquing or whatever your
body's going to recycle all that and
turn that into brand new proteins the
other cool thing about taking a cold
shower is that it will help lower
cortisol that means it's going to reduce
your stress
okay
also it's going to create better
recovery so if you're an athlete okay
and you're sore and you need faster
recovery
coal therapy is the way to go i remember
long ago when my wife and i went to the
dominican republic and uh i remember we
walked off the beaten path
and found this little oasis this little
um
like building and they had all these
different uh little baths and they were
like
they looked like little jacuzzis but
some were really really cold and some
were really really hot they had like
freezing
lukewarm hot really hot and so on and
that was a really
interesting introduction to cold therapy
because at first it didn't make sense to
me why would anyone want to jump into
some cold bath right but we both tried
it out and it was freezing but then of
course we went into the warmer bath and
the hot jacuzzi and i remember feeling
really incredible after doing that my
body was just like
feeling amazing and i slept great and
then i kind of forgot about it for some
years now coming full circle here i am
talking about exposing yourself to cold
so anyway here's the 10 benefits of cold
showers and think about it if you can
experience these benefits from just a
cold shower i mean you're already
probably taking a shower every day all
you have to do is turn it to the cold
for a little bit and then turn it back
to the hot and i'm going to show you now
what i would recommend i would do this
when you're in the shower
start with the hot shower okay
get comfortable get really hot take the
hot shower feel comfortable and then
turn it to the cold
okay i mean a nice cold shower not
lukewarm but really cold
for about 30 seconds
now anyone can handle 30 seconds right
and then turn it back to hot and then
just have that as your introduction to
the cold the next day you go in there
start to increase the 30 seconds to
maybe 40 seconds okay and then the next
shower turn up to 50 seconds and
gradually increase this to the point
where you're taking a cold shower
for
5
to 10
minutes but if you do it gradually it
won't be that uncomfortable in fact the
benefits that you're going to see are
going to be mind-blowing and you're
going to finally realize you should have
did this a long time ago what's
interesting you have all these feedback
systems in in the body
that when you expose your body to a very
cold sensation it actually warms up the
internal core of your body you actually
get more circulation internally the flip
side of that when you take a hot shower
it actually cools down the inside of
your core this is why taking a hot
shower before bed might be a good thing
because it's going to cool down your
body and you're going to sleep better
the body sleeps better when it's
slightly colder but anyway this might be
an easy way to approach this cold shower
unless you want to just do a cold turkey
and just jump right in now the other
thing that i want to mention is
infrared saunas okay
use a lower temperature than a
traditional sauna so they use like 120
to 140 degrees fahrenheit versus
traditional saunas which are 150 to 180
degrees fahrenheit now this has nothing
to do with a cold therapy but the only
point of bringing it up is that it's not
as hot as a traditional therapy and
there's some real interesting hormetic
effects to infrared which i will share
in another video real soon but anyway as
you can see if you did cold therapy for
14 days
you would see remarkable health benefits
now if you haven't seen my recent video
on the benefits of fasting
you have to see that check it out right
here
you